[Music]
in conclusion
the most christmas movie is the movie
with factually
mathematically the most christmas i hear
you
i see where you're coming from however
counterpoint
a christmas movie need not invoke the
trappings of christmas or even the
spirit of christmas
and that's why spring breakers is
the most christmas movie i feel like
you're stretching things a little thin
with that one
maybe maybe a skosh thin thinner than
the last
smear of frosting on the final
gingerbread man you know like after
you're basically out of icing but you
still only have one cookie left
dan it's that then okay sure
but consider for a moment that what
truly defines a christmas movie
isn't the tinsel or reindeer the fur
trees or plum pudding
charity carols or ghosts of christmas
past
a christmas movie is a movie that we
watch at christmas
that film that we put on every year
because it brings us together
[Music]
you know that's a really beautiful point
dan thanks
i stole it from your video
what is a christmas movie nobody knows
not really and i'm not being snide
because at the root of it a christmas
movie is defined by
social consensus and social consensus is
a
nebulous thing constantly shifting as
opinions push
and pull at it a comprehensive taxonomy
of christmas movies
is impossible it can't be done even
if they appear to be as pristine and
unimpeachable as
this a by-axis grid sorting movies along
the axes of
candy cane and christmas spirit
organized from
purist to radical the target is
constantly shifting
you can try but you'll never fully
capture the breadth
of what people treat as a christmas
movie
i know it seems unbelievable that a
system as superficially flawless
as the 3x3 morality grid could actually
be lacking
but it's true even this system brilliant
inspired divine as it may be
will still generate pointless circular
twitter arguments about movies at the
fringes
don't forget to tag your arguments with
the hashtag candykane radical
the trick is that you'll never fully
capture the breadth of what people treat
as a christmas movie
because it's not just a categorization
exercise
you're not just tracking wild reindeer
who are
otherwise oblivious to the efforts and
intentions of humans
you're asking questions of humans and
humans are
aware of the efforts and intentions
of humans it's actually an opposed
system and
some of the participants are
deliberately trying to confuse the
process
in the spirit of christmas we can
illustrate this using
toys some competitive games like magic
the gathering or league of legends
use a draft format where opponents take
turns selecting
options from a finite pool this format
opens up a strategy
called counter-picking where you take an
option not
strictly because it's something you want
but because of how
it will impact the choices available to
the opponent
maybe it's strong against something
they've chosen or maybe
it combos well with their pick and so
you take it purely
so they can't even if you have no
intention of using it
it is a response not to the immediate
state of the game
but to the idea of the game itself
a decision on making decisions i bring
it up just to illustrate that
people are aware that they're being
asked
questions that their answers will
potentially impact
outcomes when we are asked what's your
favorite christmas movie
we are conscious of the fact that there
are stereotypical answers that our
answers
will reflect on our sensibilities and
that other people will potentially
react to our pick and this meta
knowledge
impacts the way that we pick our answers
some people give answers that are most
true to them
some people give answers that they think
others want to hear
and some people give answers that they
believe will confound
the question it is a counter pick a meta
decision
choosing something that technically
adheres to the taxonomy
but in subversive if not deliberately
tenuous ways knowing that the answers
are ultimately tautological die hard has
become the ur
example here it is a story that takes
place at christmas
because it makes sense within the story
for the criminals to do their heist when
everyone is busy with christmas eve
but otherwise has little to do
with christmas it wasn't even considered
to be a defining element of the film's
identity
as the film was originally released in
july
also the b plot is about a cop who
killed a kid
harnessing the power of christmas to
regain the confidence
to shoot people again is that weird
that feels weird in fact the fascination
with whether or not die hard
is a christmas movie itself an annual
argument at this point
is largely a product of the last decade
so when asked what's your favorite
christmas movie
you answer oh it's die hard because
as an answer it's funny the person gets
offended
a christmas movie is wholesome but you
picked something full of cussing and
violence
you scamp funny thing is
it's worked christmas movies defy
comprehensive classification because
they are
self-defining christmas movies are the
movies
people say are christmas movies and thus
if enough people say
die hard is their favorite christmas
movie then
it is a christmas movie this is the
unending taxonomic negotiation that
makes
a comprehensive definition impossible
some people
will always want to trick the system but
this
raises an important question should
these kinds of counterpicks be
excluded should we go out of our way to
exclude
die hard because we know why people are
picking it
on one hand they meet the classical
definition of trolling
a deliberately inflammatory choice that
prods at the edges of definitions
on the other hand what's your favorite
christmas movie
is an inherently trivial exercise with
non-existent stakes so maybe to answer
that question we need to take it a step
further
why do people troll these conversations
and what do we gain
or lose if we take the answers
authentically
i think the answer there is in belonging
christmas is a complicated holiday it is
both a high holy day for most of the
christian
faith competing with easter in its
significance and it is also the central
holiday of the secular world
of course that relationship is not
coincidental the one
following from the other and neither was
always the case
the significance of christmas in
christianity has fluctuated over the
centuries
and the secular observance is derived
from the christian tradition
explicitly a secularization of the
holiday
thus the two holidays called christmas
are codependent nigh inseparable with
iconography and traditions
constantly interchanging to the point
that for many
the two are the same christmas is
monolithic
in our culture in a way few things are
even capable of being
and people have interesting
relationships with monoliths
cultural monoliths are things that
persist beyond the scope of a human
lifetime
binding generations together they are
things that are so
ingrained into the world that they feel
like they've
always been there that they are
self-evident
now it's not a novel observance that
traditions
tie people together across generations
but in this case i think that's maybe
missing the trees for the forest don't
get me wrong
the big picture is important feeling
connected
to history is important but it's maybe
sacrificing the
immediate value for the more poetic
answer
i want to make an argument here in favor
of tradition
without strictly arguing for
traditionalism
because many traditional societal
stances are harmful hurtful
deliberately exclusionary punitive and
oppressive
there is sometimes an understandable
instinct to reject
everything even superficially related
traditionalism
is the argument that things are per se
good
because they are traditional again
another tautology
and that's not what i'm saying here i
don't think traditions or ritual
are in any way above criticism but i
think it's
good to have traditions to have
rituals because of what they do for the
individual
ritual is valuable because ritual is an
outward signifier of stability in order
to observe ritual
particularly ones tied to a specific
time of year then you need to be stable
enough
to keep track of the year and you need
the time
and space to observe the ritual thus the
ritual observance
is a performance of stability
when people on twitter talk about
self-care this is often the instinct
that they are pointing at
small personal rituals that reclaim
time from inhumane systems i am going to
stand in this warm shower until the hot
water runs out and there is
nothing my boss can do to stop me humans
are very bad at experiencing time
a year has no innate meaning to our
bodies
and traditions help anchor us as many
people have learned during the pandemic
of 2020
life without temporal anchors gets
weird and depressing it is not
psychologically good for you they are
things to look forward to things to look
back on and large social traditions
provide a
common reference point for us to
calibrate ourselves around
and in our society christmas
is that monolithic reference point this
is where we get into the dueling desires
of the human psyche the need
to be different unique independent but
also
welcome and accepted the want for
space that we define but for that space
to be part of a whole the instinct to
reject social ritual paired with a
desire to see
oneself reflected in social ritual
people counter-pick christmas movies
because they don't want to just
adopt the hegemonic christmas they don't
want christmas to just be served
to them they want christmas but on their
own
terms so should the troll answers be
excluded
should the counterpicks be ignored well
in a way it doesn't matter it's not the
movie
that's actually important it's the
argument itself
that's the ritual it's a way of staking
a claim
to a shared social experience this is a
social negotiation process
a series of pressures within and without
the definitions of society
pushing to create or deny the space for
existence the space to belong
it's a negotiation far older than die
hard far
older than movies older than christmas
and it'll be around
long after all of us are gone
so from all of us at folding ideas and
film joy
whether it's die hard or it's a
wonderful life batman returns or a
christmas carol
may your ritual debate of what's really
a christmas movie
be filled with cheer
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you